hello kim hey david so let's talk about
the lost colony at roanoke so this is
something i've been learning a lot about
lately and i think it's really
interesting you know we often think
about this just in terms of the
spookiness of there's this colony and it
disappeared and we still don't know what
happened to it but actually i think it
has a lot to say about the process of
colonization in the new world and the
many political and weather and economic
factors that went into making a colony
successful or not successful so
set this up for me what what is going on
during the period of this early
settlement of what they called virginia
but actually turned out to be where kim
and north carolina so this is on the
outer banks and it's today uh still
roanoke island but uh one of these sort
of barrier islands off the coast of
north carolina so great place to put a
ship
actually what they call this area is the
graveyard of the atlantic so i'm hearing
not so much right so this is an area
where there are a lot of shoals uh lots
of ships run around there if you ever go
to one of the museums on the outer banks
you can see this incredibly long listing
of all of the ships that sank off the
coast of north carolina it is a very
difficult place to sail what year is it
when we first see when we see the first
colonization attempt at roanoke the
first expedition right this all starts
in the late 1570s with a man named
humphrey gilbert and gilbert is
convinced
this is actually sir walter raleigh he's
cute yes gilbert's uh half brother as it
turns out but so sir walter brawley's
half brother humphrey gilbert thinks
that it might be possible to make your
way to
the indies and fabulous riches make that
line a little bit bigger
by going on top of north america so he
thinks there's a waterway here okay so
he convinces queen elizabeth then on the
throne of england to give him a charter
to
try to plant a colony somewhere on this
side of north america so they're looking
for the northwest passage right
they're looking for the northwest
passage they're hoping that they can
find gold and what they want to do more
than anything else is just mess up
spain's chances in the new world because
spain starting with christopher columbus
has been the leading old world power in
the new world they're just like trucking
back the gold and silver and most of
what england has done up until this
point is find spanish ships that are
coming back from mexico from the west
indies and put what are called
privateers which is a nice uh word that
the english used to mean pirate to steal
state sanctioned piracy state-sanctioned
piracy so like shakespeare is like a
young man at this time right like that
is that is the period of elizabethan
england that we're looking at right now
yeah it's kind of in some ways a golden
age but when you think about how well
the english are doing when it comes to
colonization it is not a golden age they
are way behind so they're hoping maybe
they can find a northwest passage to get
all of the goodies over here in india
and the spice islands
they're hoping that maybe they could
find some good minerals in this area get
some gold of their own but at the very
least they like a nice port from which
their ships could go out and steal more
stuff from spanish ships
sure
this is a good this is their plan so
this is kind of if you'll permit me this
feels analogous to the space race during
the cold war absolutely so spain is this
economic superpower that seems to have a
one you know has have a leg up on
england just like how the soviet union
launched sputnik first
uh got a satellite into orbit above
earth and that spurred the united states
to be like no we're gonna have a moon
shot yeah and it kind of turns out the
same way in some in some aspects because
you know as we know we're sitting here
in california were speaking english
because eventually england is going to
win its way to dominance in this entire
region but originally spain gets off to
the fast start and england is just
desperate to catch up so unfortunately
sir humphrey gilbert dies uh he is so
not he's not this guy here right but
queen elizabeth then his half brother
sir walter raleigh
uh which he spelled with no i so we'll
do that but today the city that's named
after him we still spell with an eye he
picked up his half-brother's contract
which said he had to get a colony in the
new world within six years of 1578. so
he is under the gun to try to get
something happening
on the coast of north america by
1584
at the latest
so he picks up his friends and decides
to put together what i kind of term as
like the ocean's 11 of the actual ocean
okay
he finds
some
ship captains and soldiers
a demolitions expert a contortionist
a con man
similar uh he this is like the the 1500s
version of this uh he gets an artist
who we'll talk a lot more about that's
that's john white ah that's john white
he gets cartographers he gets what he
considers his a team to go out and
explore this coast pick up where his
half brother left off the only problem
was that sir walter raleigh and queen
elizabeth
were
sweethearts
and she
forbid him for from going on this
dangerous journey after all his brother
had also died on this journey so she
loved him too much said
you can't go
but his friends went so this is their
first journey and they go to north
carolina they called it virginia because
this whole area they named after queen
elizabeth the virgin queen the virgin
queen and a lot of the things in this
time period are kind of named after her
because all of these fellows were trying
to capture her heart so they go and
what's really interesting about this is
that john white this artist shows us so
much about what this area was like and i
want to show you some of the paintings
that he made in this time period so who
were the native people that this
expedition encountered
so they end up on the barrier islands of
north carolina um and you this is where
the colonists will eventually settle
here
roanoke island
the major native american groups in this
area were algonquian speaking
okay uh so
they are
kind of in the middle of
what we call the east coast today
so this is a tidewater people there are
tidewater people um you can see that
they live in long houses like other
algonquian peoples and these are
primarily the secotan people
and the croatoan people
initially the english people get along
with them pretty well they exchange you
know skins and
food lots of things the english come
back thinking this is a this is a pretty
good deal so john white and company john
white and sir walter raleigh's 11 or
however many right returned to england
right and they say this is a great place
for us to settle so then they send a
second expedition from england this time
with just soldiers it's very similar to
how jamestown is going to work out a
little bit later which is to say they
send sailors they send
soldiers
and they send people who might for
example be good at finding gold so
artisans
and they're hoping to kind of get rich
quick they think maybe there are
mountains nearby that might have gold or
gems in them or perhaps they they're
always asking the native people do you
have anything shiny have you heard of
anything that's shiny nearby because
they want to make their investors back
in england happy by making a big profit
so this is like halfway between a
forward operating base and a trading
post exactly okay um so they're not
thinking about long-term settlement but
they're left there over the winter with
the secotan people um and this is just a
bunch of rowdy soldiers who thought they
were going to get rich quick and they
don't because there's no gold in north
carolina not like there is in the south
that the spanish do so well with and
they quickly come to grief with native
americans they steal a lot of their food
who steals who's food so the english
steal the food of the seekertans and
they end up getting into a brawl over
the possible theft of a silver cup
they think really yeah they think the
native americans have stolen a silver
cup from them they demand it back the
native americans say we don't know what
you're talking about and then the
english kill a bunch of people oh my
gosh so
relations that were going pretty well
went pretty badly over what i think is
kind of a minor incident
but by the time that the
supplies
show up because the english are sending
supply ships on a regular basis sir
francis drake of piracy fame shows up
with supplies and a bunch of these 100
men just get back on the ship and sail
to england so wait before we go back to
england with these men what contributed
to this disproportionate response of
like killing a bunch of people over a
single silver cup i think a lot of it
was that many of these men now and on
later expeditions are english veterans
of the war in ireland so there's an
irish rebellion against english rule
there and english take a very brutal
stance toward the irish they just burn
their villages they decapitate irish
people and line their heads along
sidewalks i'm not making this up
so they're they're veterans of this
really brutal irish repression
and
this is something that i think you see a
lot with english people when they first
are meeting native americans they treat
them like they treated the irish which
is to say very badly they treat them as
savages or a different religion who need
to be subject to the english and need to
be taught early on that they need to
obey the english so what happened after
that kim we'll get to that in the next
video